[Music]
yeah be your best self today love with
your whole heart remember that you may
not be an angel but you're just about
the next best thing
have a great day have a great
I think everyone should hear that that's
really sweet
there aren't enough positive words like
this around if you find no love put love
and you will find love never stop
seeking that next adventure I think this
is really true because you should always
look forward to what you can do in the
future
what are you imagine yourself in 10
years only my own business is like
having like property management and
stuff like that like a corking complex
and stuff right now I'm in accounting
I'm a private accountant so I'm just
trying to save up my money to later on
now like assets make it a wonderful
stand
work my way up in the construction field
because my major is construction
management so definitely want to see
myself if not owning a design-build
construction company then definitely be
high up in one and I mean personally I
would want to either move to a big city
alright there's a lot of construction
work and a lot of culture so San Diego
there's a lot of places to go a lot of
people to meet a lot of things to see
together yeah basically yeah all they
count what's your biggest regret
this is sort of stupid but I got elected
to go to a Leadership Conference when I
was a kid and I couldn't go because I
was having a really rough time with my
family living in a household that was
not great and I really wish I could have
gone to that I feel like that would have
had a different impact at least on maybe
the next five years of my life and I
would have
not struggled in the ways that I did
if you have regrets let go of them and
forgive yourself and forgive the other
people that were involved in those
regrets
you know give up hope for that better
past and really focus on the present and
what you have in that moment and how you
can best move forward in a good way so
you don't have any regrets what is
sacred to you well Jesus Christ
my wife the good Lord family yeah family
love a being out here be very very
blessed and yeah that's an awesome
question have love in your heart and
spread it to others
pass it on to everyone every step back
is a new passage to new goal bears chew
in many ways
if you're down and out there's all the
way the new silver lining going to the
top fear is not an option
it stays outside belief and Trust stays
inside as we travel with your life
without sound love starts from within
and works itself out it kind of is just
the way life goes
it's - you just kind of gotta keep going
through it
[Music]
what's up guys my name is Raya and I'm
the owner of this channel
I'm also the person behind the camera
thought I'd take a minute to thank all
the subscribers I gained so far and
maybe ask the new viewers to the
subscribe button if you liked this
episode or if you're in my channel in
general and yeah into the subscribers
that I have already if you want to help
grow my channel it would mean a lot if
you share in your favorite episode
friend or two or three or one and help
me gain more subscribers a lot thank you
[Music]
[Music]